(deep drum and bass music)
- What you got on my bars, Hemi?
- First! (blonde person beat
boxing)
They call me Jamal and
I'm out here getting it
At the buffet, I'll be
hittin' it and quitin' it
(laughing)
Game almost over, I ain't got
no burn
'Cause coach a hate,
but that nig' gon' learn
Yeah you didn't know your boy
had flavor like that right?
- Okay then,
Softie, say I ain't really
black
Like they ain't heard
about the nine that I pack
- [Skinny And Fat Man] Oh!
- Oh, you bitch want my stinky
flows?
Y'all can't do nothing
right, drop that shit.
Y'all out here messin'
around, acting like suckers,
That's why y'all some no
playing mother (beeping).
(coach laughs)
- [Benched Players] Bars!
Legends
What